shaun of life is it black consents and
pepsi in chiffon dances about pinocchio
slightly different then virgilio sieni and
workshop well on display alessandro
schiattarella atlas of white a little and
virgilio sieni pupi pomp francesca casa
[Music]
my name is giuseppe in short, Italian and I
started to  dancing casually ten years ago
for an Italian choreographer
virgilio sieni who wanted to know
some things about blind people
aspects of movement and from there I
started a path through
different types of dance but always
remaining, let's say, close to that of
virgilio and then gradually also  from this
path after several years there are about
5 years and 6 I have come to know
different other artists and also
companies that
work with disabled people through
international exchanges such as the one
that brought us here to maastricht
for the workshop and from there from that
moment  he also started working in other
let's say countries outside Italy with
al  three different choreographers
[Music]
the first solo I did with virgilio
gara atlas del bianco and it was a
study on how colors influence
movement and how to explain
a color with movement and there are
small passages of this performance
in which it was precisely  a white room
recreated a completely white space and
was flooded with color and through
a particular color the movement
in the scene changed totally
[Music]
to be able to access has made dance
to do to be an artist in general
and  in a professional way to
people with disabilities in my opinion this is
an important fact there is power that
these people can
access freely for example or the
elections of schools
where they can enrich themselves was culturally enriched with
practically
everything they need to become
professionals  in a field like that can
be the art the dance or other
type of other this  I wish it were
possible this would be a mission
[Music]